de jouer certains des meilleurs rôles masculins
jamais représentés à la télévision.
Vous me reconnaissez peut-être comme étant « Escorte masculine n°1 ».
(Rires)
« Violeur de la session photo »,
« Violeur torse nu du rencard »
du film primé « Panique sur la côte ».
(Rires)
« Etudiant en médecine torse nu »,
« Escroc sous stéroïde torse nu »
et, dans mon rôle le plus connu, Rafael.
(Applaudissements)
Un ancien dragueur sombre
qui tombe amoureux d'une vierge
et qui est occasionnellement torse nu.
(Rires)
Ces rôles ne représentent pas
le genre d'homme que je suis dans ma vraie vie,
mais c'est ce que j'aime avec la comédie.
Je vis dans des personnages très différents de moi.
Mais chaque fois que j'ai décroché un de ces rôles, ça m'a surpris,
car la plupart des hommes que je joue transpirent le machisme,
le charisme et le pouvoir,
et quand je regarde dans le miroir, ce n'est pas ainsi que je me vois.
Mais c'est ainsi qu'Hollywood me voyait
et, avec le temps, j'ai remarqué un parallèle
entre les rôles que je jouais en tant qu'homme
à l'écran et hors de l'écran.
Toute ma vie, j'ai prétendu être un homme que je ne suis pas.
J'ai fait semblant d'être fort quand je me sentais faible,
sûr de moi quand je doutais
et dur quand j'étais blessé.
Je pense que je me suis beaucoup donné en spectacle,
mais j'en ai marre de jouer.
Je peux vous dire que c'est exténuant
d'essayer d'être "un vrai mec" pour tout le monde tout le temps.
Pas vrai ?
(Rires)
Mon frère a entendu ça.
Aussi longtemps que je m'en souvienne, on m'a seriné
quel genre d'homme je devais devenir.
Enfant, tout ce que je voulais c'était que les autres garçons m'apprécient
mais ça voulait dire que je devais acquérir
cette vision presque dégoûtée du féminin,
et puisqu'on nous disait que le féminin est l'opposé du masculin,
je devais soit rejeter l'idée d'incarner une de ces qualités
ou faire face au rejet moi-même.
C'est le scénario qu'on m'a donné.
Les filles sont faibles et les garçons sont forts.
C'est ce qu'on communique inconsciemment
à des centaines de millions de jeunes garçons et filles à travers le monde,
comme pour moi.
Je suis venu ici pour dire, en tant qu'homme,
que c'est mauvais, c'est toxique
et ça doit prendre fin.
(Applaudissements)
Je ne suis pas ici pour donner une leçon d'histoire.
Nous savons tous comment nous en sommes arrivés là.
Je ne suis qu'un gars qui a réalisé au bout de 30 ans
que je vivais dans un état de conflit,
conflit entre qui je pense être au fond de moi
et l'homme que le monde me dit que je devrais être.
Je n'ai pas envie
de m'adapter à l'actuelle définition imparfaite de la masculinité
car je ne veux pas me contenter d'être un homme bien.
Je veux être un bon être humain.
Et je crois que pour que ça arrive,
les hommes doivent apprendre à embrasser les qualités
en nous que l'on dit féminines,
mais aussi être prêts à prendre partie,
à soutenir et à apprendre des femmes qui les incarnent.
Pour les hommes --
(Rires)
je ne dis pas que tout ce que nous avons appris est toxique.
Ou que quelque chose cloche intrinsèquement chez vous ou moi
ou que nous devons arrêter d'être des hommes.
Mais nous avons besoin d'équilibre.
Nous avons besoin d'équilibre
et la seule façon de changer les choses est de considérer honnêtement
les scénarios qui nous ont été transmis
de génération en génération
et les rôles que, en tant qu'hommes, nous choisissons d'assumer
dans notre vie quotidienne.
En parlant de scénarios,
le premier scénario que j'ai reçu venait de mon père.
Mon père était génial.
Il est aimant, gentil, sensible, encourageant.
Il est ici.
(Applaudissements)
Il pleure.
(Rires)
Mais désolé papa, quand j'étais enfant, je le méprisais pour ça
car je lui en voulais de me rendre tendre,
ce qui n'était pas bienvenu dans la petite ville
où nous avions emménagé.
Être tendre signifiait être malmené.
Mon père n'était pas traditionnellement masculin,
alors il ne m'a pas appris à utiliser mes mains.
Il ne m'a pas appris à chasser, à me battre,
les trucs de mecs.
Au lieu de ça, il m'a appris ce qu'il savait :
qu'être un homme était question de sacrifice
et de faire tout votre possible
pour prendre soin et nourrir votre famille.
Mais il y a un autre rôle que j'ai appris à jouer avec mon père
qui l'a appris de son père,
un sénateur
qui plus tard dans sa vie
a dû travailler comme gardien de nuit pour nourrir sa famille
et ne l'a jamais dit à personne.
Ce rôle était de souffrir en secret.
Trois générations plus tard,
je joue également ce rôle.
Pourquoi mon grand-père n'a-t-il pas pu faire appel à un autre homme
et demander de l'aide ?
Pourquoi, jusqu'à aujourd'hui, mon père croit-il toujours devoir tout faire seul ?
Je connais un homme qui préférerait mourir
que de dire à un autre qu'il souffre.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'il est du genre fort et silencieux.
Non. Beaucoup d'hommes savent très bien se faire des amis et parler,
mais pas de quelque chose de vrai.
(Rires)
S'il s'agit de travail, de sport, de politique ou de femmes,
nous pouvons partager nos opinions,
mais s'il s'agit de nos insécurités, de nos difficultés,
de notre peur de l'échec,
c'est comme si nous étions paralysés.
Tout du moins c'est mon cas.
Certaines des méthodes que j'ai essayées
pour me libérer de ce comportement
sont la création d'expériences me forçant à être vulnérable.
Si je ressens de la honte au sujet de quelque chose dans ma vie,
je m'entraîne à me diriger droit dessus,
peu importe à quel point c'est effrayant,
parfois même publiquement.
En faisant ça,
je lui ôte son pouvoir
et ma manifestation de vulnérabilité
peut parfois donner à d'autres hommes la permission de faire de même.
En guise d'exemple, il y a quelque temps,
j'étais aux prises avec un problème
dont je savais qu'il fallait que je parle à mes amis masculins,
mais j'étais si paralysé par la peur
qu'ils me jugent, me considèrent faible
et que je perde ma position de meneur
que je savais qu'il me fallait les amener hors de la ville
pour une sortie entre gars --
(Rires)
Juste pour m'ouvrir. Et devinez quoi ?
Ce n'est qu'à la fin du troisième jour
que j'ai trouvé la force de leur parler
de ce que je traversais.
Mais alors, une chose géniale s'est produite.
J'ai réalisé que je n'étais pas seul
car mes amis avaient aussi des difficultés.
Dès que j'ai trouvé la force et le courage de partager ma honte,
elle a disparu.
J'ai appris avec le temps
que si je veux m'entraîner à être vulnérable,
je dois établir un système de responsabilisation.
J'ai été béni en tant qu'acteur.
J'ai des fans formidables,
très, très gentils et engagés,
alors j'ai décidé d'utiliser ma plateforme sociale
comme un cheval de Troie
où j'ai pu créer une pratique quotidienne d'authenticité et de vulnérabilité.
La réponse a été incroyable.
Elle a été pleine de soutien et réconfortante.
J'ai des tonnes d'amour, de presse et de messages positifs au quotidien.
Ça vient d'une certaine population :
les femmes.
(Rires)
C'est vrai.
Pourquoi n'y a-t-il que des femmes à me suivre ?
Où sont les hommes ?
(Rires)
Il y a environ un an, j'ai posté cette photo.
Après, je parcourais certains des commentaires
et j'ai remarqué qu'une de mes fans avait tagué son copain dans la photo
et son copain avait répondu en disant :
« Arrête de me taguer dans de la merde gay.
Merci. »
(Rires)
Comme si être gay vous rendait moins homme.
J'ai inspiré profondément
et j'ai répondu.
J'ai dit,
très poliment, j'étais juste curieux
car j'explore la masculinité
et je voulais savoir pourquoi mon amour pour ma femme
était de la merde gay.
Alors j'ai dit qu'honnêtement, je ne voulais qu'apprendre.
(Rires)
Il m'a répondu immédiatement.
J'ai cru qu'il allait s'en prendre à moi, mais au lieu de cela, il s'est excusé.
Il m'a raconté comment, en grandissant,
les témoignages publics d'affection étaient méprisés.
Il m'a dit qu'il luttait et se débattait avec son ego,
combien il aimait sa copine
et combien il était reconnaissant pour sa patience.
Quelques semaines plus tard,
il m'a renvoyé un message.
Il m'a envoyé une photo
de lui à genoux, la demandant en mariage.
(Applaudissements)
Il a simplement dit « Merci ».
J'ai été ce gars-là.
Je comprends.
Publiquement, il ne faisait que jouer son rôle,
rejeter le féminin.
Mais secrètement, il attendait la permission de s'exprimer,
d'être vu, d'être entendu
et il lui suffisait qu'un autre homme
le tienne responsable et crée un lieu sûr où il puisse ressentir
et la transformation fut instantanée.
J'adore cette expérience
car elle m'a montré que la transformation est possible,
même par messages.
Je voulais découvrir comment toucher plus d'hommes,
mais aucun d'entre eux ne me suivait.
(Rires)
Alors j'ai fait une expérience.
J'ai commencé à poster des choses stéréotypées plus masculines --
(Rires)
Comme mes entraînements intenses, mon programme alimentaire,
mon parcours pour guérir mon corps après une blessure.
Devinez ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Des hommes ont commencé à m'écrire.
Puis, soudainement, pour la première fois de ma carrière,
un magazine de fitness masculin m'a appelé
et a dit vouloir m'honorer en tant que personne changeant la donne.
(Rires)
Est-ce que ça changeait la donne
ou était-ce seulement s'y conformer ?
C'est ça le problème.
C'est cool pour les hommes de me suivre
quand je parle de trucs de mecs
et que je me conforme aux normes de genre.
Mais si je parle de combien j'aime ma femme
ou ma fille ou mon fils de 10 ans,
combien je crois que le mariage est un magnifique défi,
comment, en tant qu'homme, je souffre de dysmorphie corporelle
ou si je promeus l'égalité des sexes, seules les femmes se manifestent.
Où sont les hommes ?
Alors, les hommes, les hommes, les hommes,
les hommes !
(Applaudissements)
Je comprends.
En grandissant, nous nous défions les uns les autres.
Nous devons être l'homme le plus dur,
le plus fort, le plus courageux que nous pouvons.
Pour beaucoup d'entre nous, moi y compris, nos identités sont enveloppées
dans le fait qu'à la fin de la journée nous nous sentions assez homme ou pas.
Mais j'ai un défi pour tous les mecs,
car les hommes aiment les défis.
(Rires)
Je vous défie d'utiliser les mêmes qualités
qui à votre avis, font de vous un homme
pour aller plus profond en vous.
Votre force, votre courage, votre robustesse :
pouvons-nous redéfinir leur sens et les utiliser pour explorer notre cœur ?
Êtes-vous assez courageux
pour être vulnérable ?
Pour faire appel à un autre homme quand vous avez besoin d'aide ?
Pour plonger tête la première dans votre honte ?
Êtes-vous assez fort pour être sensible,
pour pleurer quand vous avez mal
ou quand vous êtes heureux,
même si vous semblez faible ?
Avez-vous assez confiance en vous
pour écouter les femmes dans votre vie ?
Pour entendre leurs idées et leur solutions ?
Pour contenir leur angoisse
et les croire vraiment,
même si ce qu'elles disent est contre vous ?
Serez-vous assez homme
pour tenir tête aux autres hommes
en entendant « ces discussions de vestiaires »,
ces histoires de harcèlement sexuel ?
Quand vous entendez vos mecs parler de saisir un cul ou de la faire boire,
prendrez-vous position et agirez-vous
pour qu'un jour nous n'ayons pas à vivre dans un monde
où une femme doit tout risquer
pour se manifester et dire les mots « moi aussi » ?
(Applaudissements)
C'est sérieux.
J'ai dû considérer vraiment et honnêtement
les façons dont j'ai inconsciemment blessé les femmes dans ma vie
et c'est moche.
Ma femme m'a dit que je m'étais comporté d'une façon qui la blessait
et que je n'avais pas changé ça.
Parfois, quand elle parlait,
à la maison ou en public,
je l'interrompais en milieu de phrase et finissait sa pensée pour elle.
C'est horrible.
Le pire est que je n'avais absolument pas conscience de le faire.
C'était inconscient.
Ici, je fais ma part,
j'essaye d'être un féministe,
d'amplifier les voix des femmes à travers le monde
et pourtant à la maison,
j'utilise ma voix plus forte
pour faire taire la femme que j'aime le plus.
Je devais me poser une question difficile :
est-ce que je suis suffisemment un vrai mec
pour me taire et écouter ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je dois être honnête, j'aurais aimé ne pas être applaudi.
(Rires)
Les gars,
c'est réel.
Je ne fais que gratter un peu la surface,
car plus on va profond, plus c'est moche, je vous le garantis.
Je n'ai pas le temps de parler de porno, de violence envers les femmes,
de la division des tâches ménagères,
de l'inégalités des salaires.
Je crois qu'en tant qu'hommes,
il est temps de voir au-delà de notre privilège
et reconnaître ne pas être qu'une partie du problème.
Les gars, nous sommes le problème.
Le plafond de verre existe car nous l'avons placé là
et si nous voulons faire partie de la solution,
les mots ne suffisent plus.
Il y a une citation des écritures baha'ies avec laquelle j'ai grandi et que j'adore.
Elle dit : « le monde de l'humanité possède deux ailes,
l'une mâle, l'autre femelle.
Si les deux ailes ne sont pas également fortes,
l'oiseau ne peut s'envoler. »
Aux femmes,
de la part de tous les hommes du monde
qui se sentent comme moi,
s'il vous plaît, pardonnez-nous
pour toutes nos façons de ne pas compter sur votre force.
J'aimerais formellement vous demander de nous aider
car nous ne pouvons pas y arriver seuls.
En tant qu'hommes, nous allons échouer.
Nous ne dirons pas ce qu'il faut, ne prêterons pas attention au ton.
Nous allons probablement vous offenser.
Mais ne perdez pas espoir.
Nous ne sommes là que grâce à vous
et, comme vous, en tant qu'hommes, nous devons devenir des alliés
alors que vous vous battez
contre presque tout.
Nous avons besoin de votre aide pour célébrer notre vulnérabilité
et de votre patience envers nous
au cours de ce très long chemin
de notre tête vers notre cœur.
Finalement, aux parents :
au lieu d'apprendre à nos enfants
à être des garçons courageux ou des filles jolies,
pouvons-nous leur apprendre à être de bons êtres humains ?
Revenons-en à mon père.
En grandissant, comme tout garçon, j'ai connu des problèmes,
mais je réalise maintenant que c'est grâce à sa sensibilité
et à son intelligence émotionnelle
que je peux me tenir ici aujourd'hui pour vous parler.
Le mépris que j'éprouvais envers mon père n'avait rien à voir avec lui.
Il avait tout à voir avec moi et mon désir d'être accepté
et de jouer un rôle qui n'a jamais été pour moi.
Si mon père ne m'a pas appris comment utiliser mes mains,
il m'a appris à utiliser mon cœur
et, à mes yeux, ça fait plus de lui un homme que quoi que ce soit d'autre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)